this video is brought to you by Wix
[Music]
let's talk about Kanye West the years
2009 at the MTV Video Music Awards
Taylor Swift wins an award over Beyonce
and you might remember what happened
next I'll let you finish but Beyonce had
one of the best videos of all time
Kanye goes on to apologize and then uh
apologize and it all gets very confusing
fast forward to 2016 and Kanye's track
famous features this live I feel like me
and Taylor might still had sex why I
made that big famous dude I made that
famous the internet got mad Taylor Swift
got mad and then audio comes out that
Taylor Swift knew about and even
encouraged the song from the start like
me and Taylor might still have sex
[Music]
wait what
well this seemingly insignificant
example perfectly explains our current
cultural and political predicament and
it all has to do with a concept from
professional wrestling called kayfabe
believe it or not if we pay attention to
these guys we'll be able to better
understand what's going on with these
guys
if we're right it might be the case that
wrestling truly can explain everything
welcome to the wide world of kayfabe but
before we get into it want to give a
shout-out to our sponsor over at Wix if
you've ever thought about creating your
own website Wix will give you total
creative freedom to make a professional
and engaging website for any occasion we
even whipped up a site using their cool
community features so you guys can vote
on what kind of content you want us to
make next more on that at the end of the
video but for now back to the show
so what is a fake it's a term used to
describe the way in which professional
wrestling consists of staged events and
predetermined narratives that are
treated as true so even though everyone
knows that wrestling is scripted they
still treat it like a real athletic
competition and even when wrestlers are
off the clock and out of the ring they
never acknowledge this as this would
constitute the unholy sin known as
breaking cafe you never break a favor
[Applause]
to put this commitment to kayfabe into
perspective this would basically be like
if Matt Damon refused to accept his
drink at Starbucks unless the barista
called out the name Jason Bourne now
wrestling fans aren't idiots they of
course know that the fights are scripted
and of the wrestlers or characters but
it's not the truth of the events that
matter it's the story it's not true
because it's real it's true because it's
entertaining it's still kayfabe doesn't
just apply to any reality show that may
or may not be true you fall as this
would make 90% of modern entertainment
Kay favor is that kayfabe refers to
entertainment in which staged events are
presented as real by those producing
them and perceived as real by those
consuming them it's kind of like Santa
Claus everyone knows he's fake but
because we're all in on it and this time
we agree with you Dwayne and in case any
kiddos are watching this don't be upset
while Santa Claus is a lie so is God so
remove the shackles from your tiny souls
and dare to live a life beyond good and
evil but much like John Cena kayfabe
didn't stick to just wrestling for long
and in a manner reminiscent of Dwayne
Johnson himself hey babe has now
infected the entire entertainment
industry and as we'll soon see
our lives and while professional
wrestling is unsurprisingly full of
Floridians another famous Floridian has
used kayfabe in a seemingly unlikely
medium rap music Rick Ross who is
basically the Santa Claus of Miami
my new battalion DC community
development has built a career on the
narrative that he's a legendary boss in
the drug game comparing himself to
infamous kingpins and countless songs
however pictures leaked which revealed
that the boss with a belly full of rows
a spent his younger years as a
corrections officer
so rather than ducking the law Rick Ross
was enforcing it many assumed this would
be the end of his career how do you feel
about bosses giving you the name Officer
Ricky I just want to hear from you baby
I'm worth too much money to even be you
know sidetracked on this coffee but it
had very little effect
Ross responded with a vacant estat would
make a French New Wave van prowl it's
about who Rosie is is about me when
anywhere I go in that step in the room I
put it down people know this authentic
right here they know it's real so let's
go get this money let's make this music
and his career has only grown since
kayfabe can help us understand this as
the fans prefer the narrative of Ross as
a Miami drug kingpin over the truth of
his career in law enforcement
and why would Ross care what's true and
what's not as long as he's selling
records we could see another use of
kayfabe in the world of YouTube's most
infamous brothers the Paul's
in a move that would likely confused
Rick Ross the two brothers often engage
in a back and forth beef via YouTube
videos along with making Aaron Carter
look hardcore by comparison this battle
can be best analyzed as a clever use of
kayfabe to game the YouTube algorithm to
get the brothers more clicks and more
dollars and just in case Rick Ross is
watching this Rick we will gladly send
you a free wisecrack hoodie if you post
your own rap video that shuts the Paul's
up once and for all and if Ross did this
it would make him a shooter which is a
kayfabe term for someone who makes the
violence in wrestling reel before we go
on it's worth noting how calf Abe is
also distinct from satire while for both
the performer and the audience are in on
the joke satire is used precisely to
point us toward the
absurdity of the actual truth rather
than create a new one for example
Stephen Colbert engaged in satire on The
Colbert Report I don't even see race not
even my own people tell me I'm white and
I believe them because I just devoted
six minutes to explain me how I'm not a
racist as his character was used to
exemplify the absurdity of cable news
host like Bill O'Reilly but Infowars
host Alex Jones can be better analyzed
via kayfabe I'm a pioneer I'm an
explorer I'm a human and I'm common his
insane claims are always presented in
the guise of political truth and the
audience buys into the narrative The
Colbert and O'Reilly example can help us
understand another set of terms used by
kayfabe faces and heals faces refer to
the good guys in wrestling and heals are
the bad guys and while we might out
relieve root for the faces the heels are
the ones who sell the tickets this can
help explain the polarization of the
media heels are where the money is so a
Riley & Co had their heel and Obama what
President Obama does not understand is
that he has lost all credibility in
matters of security and now the liberal
media has found their ultimate heel in
Trump what he's saying was not true
now you might be thinking that if
kayfabe only applies to the media then
why should I care well we think that
damn it Dwayne it absolutely does matter
because the terrifying reality is that
kayfabe is an even better tool for
understanding contemporary politics a
2016 New York Times article by Jeremy
Gordon was titled is everything
wrestling which we might rephrase as is
our world becoming one elaborate kayfabe
take Alex Jones while he's known for his
subtle political arguments destroy the
child corrupt them all this is their
plan people these are demons and stellar
advertising campaigns for legit medical
supplements he recently used kayfabe to
his defense in a court of law attorney
Randal Wilhite said Jones is playing a
character on his radio show but Jones's
claim doesn't change the fact that his
show is considered a news source by his
millions of viewers and yes it can be
fun to play with this persona um
but the pizza Kate's candle shows the
dark side of Jones's brand of political
kayfabe but kayfabe isn't just being
used for the type of fringe media being
kicked off YouTube it's all over TV news
as well
CNN has acknowledged that their primary
aim is not objective news but rather
entertainment according to New York
Times profile of CNN president Jeff
Zucker as Zucker sees it his pro-trump
panelists are not just spokespeople for
a worldview they are characters and a
drama members of CNN's extended ensemble
cast Michelle wolf recently pointed out
how much cable news depends on heels and
constructed narratives his way into the
studio is so compelling you almost
forget that he was invited on and paid
and finally the biggest example of
political kayfabe might be the 45th
President of the United States Donald J
Trump no stranger to reality TV Trump is
the first politician to fully embrace
the power of kayfabe Trump has made a
number of claims that are clearly untrue
I know more about Isis than the generals
do believe this was the largest audience
to ever witness an inauguration period
and of course his threats against his
old friend Hillary Clinton it's just
awfully good that someone with the
temperament of Donald Trump is not in
charge of the law in our country because
you'd be in jail had as much truth
behind them as the beef between stone
cold in the rock but just like Rick
Ross's criminal past
it's the narrative that matters not the
facts Trump may be especially extreme in
his political cafe but politicians
across the spectrum use it just as much
while the Democrats have been vocal in
their support for fighting against
climate change the DNC has also recently
backtracked on their banned from taking
donations from the fossil fuel Lobby but
of course this won't stop their
narrative of being the party of
environmentalism so why is kayfabe
having a moment the most obvious answer
is that it allows people to ground
reality in narrative rather than
empirical truth and who wouldn't want to
live an exciting story full of heroes
villains and escalating drama as
Jeremie Gordon said in the New York
Times if a story is well told if its
history seems consistent then the
machinations putting it into place can
be temporarily overlooked or turn into a
fun story of their own and why not in
the end were all marks for a world we
want to believe it and this brings us to
our last Cafe vocab term of the day mark
which is a fan who is so excited to
believe a narrative that they lose sight
of its fictional nature and treat it as
real for the mark it's not about what is
true it's about what they want to be
true and this might be the danger of
kayfabe when it turns from a principle
of entertainment into a practical
philosophy writer Nick Rogers had this
to say in the New York Times Cathy isn't
merely a suspension of disbelief it is
philosophy about truth itself it rests
on the assumption that feelings are
inherently more trustworthy than facts
kayfabe philosophy replaces reason and
objectivity in the favor of emotion and
opinion and the most dangerous part of
this world of kayfabe is that we might
not even realize that we are in fact
marks of our own creation and before you
go be sure to click these links to check
out these videos in which we take down
our competitor website clever crevice
and their ridiculous hosts Gerald and
once you're there be sure to check out
their response to our response and of
course you'll want to see our response
to their response to our response and
after that you'll want to see our
response to their response to all
responses response and after that you'll
want to check out wisecrack fans calm
the webpage we made using this week's
sponsor Wix we're teaming up with Wix to
redesign our main site but in the
meantime we thought to see a perfect
opportunity to show off all the features
Wix has to offer right now if you head
over to our temporary site linked in the
description you can vote on which
episode of South Park you want us to
cover on our South Park podcast during
the off weeks of this season they also
have a ton of other useful features like
week's video for the professional trying
to enhance their portfolio or Wix stores
for the business owner trying to create
a clean and elegant shop no matter who
you are Wix has the solution for your
website needs if you're ready to create
your own site head to wix.com slash go
slash wisecrack or click the link in the
description thanks for watching as
always peace
[Music]
you